during her 16 years as a police officer
maggie oliver worked in major crime
when she raised concerns a blind eye was
being turned to reports of rape and
sexual abuse
maggie claims she was dismissed by
senior officers the victims the the the
women were being
dismissed they were being judged
um
that their abusers were not being
prosecuted effectively and when i tried
to raise these issues
i was
isolated i felt that i was bullied that
i was there was a great attempt to
silence me when serving police officer
wayne cousins abused his position to
kidnap rape and murder sarah everard
allegations emerged of institutional
sexism in the police inappropriate use
of social media ignoring victims needs
the prime minister is among those
calling for a change in police culture
there is a massive job of work to do to
give women the confidence that they need
and i i want to be clear i believe that
people should be confident in the police
i think that police officers men and
women up and down the country will be
absolutely sickened by what has happened
metropolitan police commissioner
cressida dick is launching a review of
internal culture within the force
and in a bid to make women feel safer
she's announced an additional 650
offices for certain urban areas
for many this doesn't go far enough the
rate of conviction for domestic abuse
among police officers is far lower than
the general public and many want to see
a zero tolerance approach the no
perpetrator should be a serving police
officer we know wayne cousins had been
reported on more than one occasion for
indecent exposure yet he remained in
post left to prowl the streets as a
dangerous predator in the guise of a
trusted police officer
for many challenging loan officers is
not the answer yet many women still feel
the onus is on them to keep themselves
safe i think the solution is to do with
the sort of management of police and
like whatever they're doing now is not
working clearly it's
i don't know it's
the police aren't i don't trust the
police and i think there's a deep and
well-founded mistrust of the policing
system in general we're not asking for
more police we're asking for better
police we're asking for
prevention education and safety
and that is the bare minimum that we can
ask for right there are far more good
officers than bad but the culture within
the police has a long way to go
in protecting women
and regaining their trust
sally lockwood sky news